Oh, there we go.
I'm so small.
I almost went to the game, my game screen, because I was
like, we're gaming, and I was like, wait a second.
No, I'm having trouble with the game.
My, my, my.
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Welcome.
I almost, I like my new loading screen so much.
I almost just want to keep it.
Running the whole time so I can just watch it over and over
again Because it's so cute It's so cute You guys like it?
Basically, my idea with it is I want to In the future, when
I get like a new outfit or when I think of something new I
want to like keep adding on to it So if we maybe we have
like another big game memory or something add on to it like
with that or and like i said a new outfit or i of course i
want to add like vicky and phoebe in the future too and
stuff so that's the that's the idea that's the idea now
eventually maybe one day it'll get so long i will i will
keep i will keep noelle and and we uh they're gonna they're
always i will be like it's time i'll i'll crawl into the dms
and i'll be like hello and they're like yes yes me though 15
minute loading it'll be so long that like it would be
different every time because because it would it wouldn't it
would be so long that the whole thing couldn't play.
So, you might be wondering, is the hot dog an official
outfit?
Yeah, baby.
You might be wondering, especially if you're watching the
VOD or did not catch me in pre-chat, I was having some
technical difficulties with Limbo.
Okay, so I'm going to explain what was happening.
So, the game does not have a Like, this is, this, this is,
like, kind of rare where I feel like I can't solve a problem
with, like, game capture.
But for some reason, the game just won't capture with, like,
normal OBS game capture.
And then when I tried to window capture it, it does not even
show up.
I guess I could desktop, I feel like my only last option, I
did not try it, is desktop.
capture, but I'm scared.
I'm scared of that option.
I guess I could do that.
I think I might have to.
Now that I think about it.
So what I was going to do was I was like, oh, well, you
know, I can play on my mini PC that I use for.
I explained that to Nimmy.
She was like, how do you play some of
computer and then you use it only for those but um uh uh
what was i saying
um oh what i was gonna do it on that because i was just like
oh i can just capture it because you know it is capturing
the computer itself and i'll play through there but then i
remembered as i was setting it up As I was setting it up, I
remembered that Steam will yell at me.
It will be like, um, no, ma'am, you are already playing
VTube Studio on another computer.
So you cannot play this game.
And then I checked if GOG had it.
And of course they don't have it.
So I was like, ah.
Yeah, wagging his finger at me.
So.
Second account.
I don't have a second account.
I don't...
Okay, I know that you can do some things in offline mode,
but I'm actually not sure how to do it.
How do I run in offline mode?
How do I do that?
It's my birthday today!
Rafa, happy birthday!
Denso2exe, the debut was so cool.
I can't wait to see all the beautiful things you're going to
do together.
Thank you!
Oh, actually, thank you for reminding me.
I do have a collab later, and I want to.
Wait, how do I?
Oh, I want to set up the raid into it.
So I don't want to forget, you know.
Redirect to Den-Setsu.
Den-Setsu.
Is playing on console not an option?
Unfortunately, I don't have it on console.
Oh no, it won't let me raid into it.
Um, Den-Setsu, um, YouTube account give me perms please what
the heck i guess i'm not a member you guys i'm just kidding
press steam top right press go offline
i see it i see it okay hold on let me install it in i didn't
install it yet let me install it on my other computer I
installed it on this computer, obviously, but...
Okay, hold on.
Good idea.
No kidding, is it?
I might be a genius.
It's also my birthday.
Mystery of y'all!
Happy birthday!
Love the new intro.
Thank you!
Why is my thing not working?
Oh, here we go.
There we go, there we go.
Um...
Close out.
Steam.
Oh my gosh, this computer's so funny.
It just has Mystery of the Druids and Harvester on it.
Steam open.
What do you mean, error?
Don't give me that.
Oh, I need to get on Wi-Fi.
Connect.
Wait, please don't ask for the password.
Please connect.
Don't ask for the password.
Yippee!
Okay.
Okay, now I have to find it.
Wait, where are you?
Hello?
Actually, I'm just going to type it in.
What am I... Oh, limbo.
We're doing it live, folks.
We're doing it live.
We're doing it live, Insta.
You may need to run the game once first before going
offline.
Okay.
Thank you.
Well, if it'll let me.
I don't know if it will.
We'll see.
Okay.
All installed.
Very cool.
Let me see if it'll let me play.
Huh?
Oh.
It got angry at me.
One ombu rice, please.
Yes.
Thank you.
Take your iPhone camera and point it at the screen.
So true.
Okay.
Go away, go away.
All right, cool.
Now let me go offline.
I'm going offline.
Okay.
Am I offline?
Yes.
All right, play.
Please play the game.
My tail.
Oh,
it disappeared.
Oh, it closed.
It crashed.
It disappeared.
Oh, every time I open the game, it...
Oh, oh, okay.
So, so...
Oh, before we play the game as well, I guess we should have
done.
dress the the the um the the jelly in the room the jellifant
hold on i gotta plug my controller into my oh where is this
plugged up into i gotta plug my controller into my uh mini
pc because i'm gonna Oh, wait.
Oh, no, it's in the back.
Oh, I thought it... Oh, gosh.
I thought it was in...
Okay, hold on.
Wait, maybe I could just use...
Okay, shh, shh, shh.
You're okay.
I'm gonna try and just find another cord.
I don't want to reach back there.
Can you hear me?
Yeah, we should discuss.
So...
Wisp...
Name.
I had two ideas that were so gracious.
given to me.
Thank you everybody for all your input.
No, I don't want to be Laboobus.
I don't want that.
Because, you know what?
Also, it will be out of style in a year.
People are already finding Laboobus in like, in like thrift
stores.
It's a tear, it's terrible.
We're not, we're just, we're not following fads.
We're not doing that.
All right, please work.
Please work.
Oh, I pray to thee.
Yeah.
Oh, oh.
It works.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited.
Good job, guys.
We did it, team.
We did it.
Now I know some people are pretty attached to the name.
I totally understand that.
You can still use it.
Um, you know, technically it's not like, it's like a normal
word.
It's not like a fan name.
So it still applies to you guys because that's like, you
know, kind of just how ghosts are a bit, you know?
So, hmm.
For those who did not see yesterday during the debut, I
admitted something very sad.
I admitted something very sad, which was that the word...
It's not whisp.
It's...
Whisps.
Bad as well.
Literal skill issue.
Yeah, you could say that.
And it has not...
gotten any better like in fact it's gotten what worse with
how i tried with me trying to say it so um i apologize that
i chose this and i can't say it so i saw some um awesome
suggestions being thrown around and some not so awesome
suggestions we can't make everybody happy um i will give two
options and i will have them two options that i really
really liked i will put them up in the pole and um we'll go
from there and you know like i said if you like wisp then
that's okay you can keep saying that too but yeah yeah we
will do that also okay good i do have it okay all right here
are the two options that i whoa what the heck schedule your
live to switch to members only oh members what the heck they
added that that's new what if i accidentally click that that
would suck okay decide your fate You can choose between
eyeball, like eyeball, or butaku, like otaku.
Yeah, start pole.
You legit had me fooled for over a year?
I would not say it very often because I was struggling so
much with it.
Oh no, I like both.
This is an extremely hard choice.
I know it is for me too.
I think they're both really cute.
Oh, I feel like I could call you guys that really, both of
them really easily.
Like, Aibu, Aibu, come help me in this game.
Or Butaku, butaku.
I feel like I'm going to get really annoying about saying it
now.
So that I can be, so I can make up for all the times that
I've not called you with.
so I feel like Aibu also kind of has like a double meaning
because I in Japanese is love so you can't even if you
choose that you can't even say that I hate you guys because
and because then it's a little double meaning why didn't you
tell is that?
Oh, what do you mean?
What do you want me to redo the poll after telling you that?
Butaku voters didn't think that.
Okay, I'll redo the poll.
You guys, okay, we'll redo it.
We'll redo it.
But put your real honest answer.
I like both of them very much.
But it's also getting friend-zoned at the same time because
you're like, Aibo, you know, your partner.
Butaku sounds like you're calling us pigs
Decide your fate, part two.
I like both.
I, boo.
Boo-taku.
Boo-u.
I like them both very much.
Yeah, I think pigs and pigs make the boo.
No, they go boo-hee, boo-hee.
they don't go boo boo
i'm officially voting no vetoed we're not keeping well like
i said you can keep for yourself but not me baby corey thank
you so much for the fun guilty
solid mint and her partner in crime buta con buta cons
actually sounds like like you're you're a freaks for pigs
you know you're not loli con you're not shota con you're
Buta kind.
Who told you?
Who told me what?
Oh, that you're a freak for the pig.
I'll be a pig for you, girl.
Boo-hee!
I-boo, like, partner.
But I feel like Buta-ku fits our theme very well because...
you know the otaku go to the maid cafes ah it's tough choice
but i see many people like eyeball i like it too very easy
to say they're both good i like them so much why not both we
can't have both we can't have both i like eyeball very much
though eyeball sounds cuter shall we choose
Are you guys my little eyeball?
My eyeballs?
My eye boobs?
I'll call you eye boobs when you're being stupid.
Hey, stop being an eye boob.
Eye boob!
Eye boob, eye boob, eye boob.
Eye boob, eye boob, eyeball, eyeball, eyeball.
Just call us my boos.
Not very social at all.
Oh my god, see those?
Thank you so much!
Why can't we be phantoms?
That's like my last name though.
Ghost Otaku?
Paranormal Superfan?
Well that's what I guess Butaku would have been.
But I think Aibu is pretty cute too.
Aibu!
Like I said, we can't make everybody happy, but I still
think this is a pretty cute name.
Hopefully it grows on you guys as well!
So, Aibu, Aibu, Aibu.
Taking your surname.
Stop!
Stop it!
I wear the pants in this relationship.
Ibu, Ibu, Ibu, Ibu, Ibu, Ibu, Ibu, Ibu.
I could say it so fast!
It's so easily!
Ibu, Ibu, Ibu, Ibu, Ibu, Ibu!
Butaku sounds somewhat adult?
you wear pants I can no
that lick pocket no you guys happy to have a new name still
fitting of this guy yeah I think so he's so I boo am I boo
yes you boo blue blue no you boo I boo you boo wee boo
I'll be your eyeball for life or afterlife that's all I have
is afterlife yay great job everybody I'm really happy with
this now now it feels like my my re-debut debut debut is all
is all complete.
I think Cash Money Robots.
We can't all be legends like him.
Ibu play name, but I won't forget it.
Well, we all just call ourselves Adamskas.
Can we pretend that is...
Wisps is our species name, but we are called Ibu.
Sure.
You know, back when I like first...
When I first...
Kind of, if you watched Phoebe's debut, she had a similar
situation where she called all of her fans the Phoebe hive,
you know.
And back when I... before I went to heaven, everybody was
called the fandom.
Which is such a great name.
But it's not like... you can't say like, I am fandom.
You know?
It's only... it's like plural only.
So...
We, uh, boo.
She's just called boo.
What if we combine both?
I think it becomes a little too much.
That's just my opinion, though.
Hmm.
Yeah, you say, like, I am in the fandom.
So, that's why when I came back, I was like, I don't think I
have, like, a fan name.
I only have, like, a fandom name.
So, it was really hard for me to think of something, and,
you know,
But now I think Aibu is very, very cute.
And you guys are still little, little wisps.
You guys are still because, you know, that's how ghosts are.
You're like the little willow wisps.
Yeah, so.
Aibu!
Alright, shall we play now?
Shall we play the game?
I got it working, so I think we will be good, I think so.
Let's try.
Let's go.
Where is it?
Wait!
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh, that's why.
Yay!
Let me turn off the music.
Okay.
saved we are saved we are saved but i want to thank
everybody again for all the suggestions they were all there
were a lot of really really great ones so um i really really
appreciate it thank you for everybody's creative brains yes
yes yes yes limbo shall we limbo
Because I'm graveyard slave.
Congrats on the redew.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the pink.
Seeing your dreams all finally coming true.
Has been worth being a fan.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, Ibu is...
Wait.
Where's my...
Why do I always lose my kazoo?
I always lose it.
Oh, there.
Happy birthday!
That's me simulating one of those things that you blow and
the confetti comes out.
Any chance that Densetsu Dai Yixi might do a cassette
release of your music?
There's a handful of us that still collect them.
I would never say never.
I don't think we have any plan at the moment, but never say
never.
Is it fandom with pH or fandom, like with an F?
Yeah, we don't have to use that though.
I know it gets convoluted.
I don't want to like, I don't want to make anything ever
confusing and people be like, wait, like, you know, I don't
want newscomers to come in and be like, am I, am I Wisp?
Am I fandom?
Am I I boo?
What's going on?
You know, so.
I want things to be as simple and easy as possible.
What are we?
What's my identity?
Everybody, everybody's going to need therapy because they
don't know.
Who they are anymore.
Who am I?
But yeah, let's start limbo.
I'm not very flexible.
I don't think I can do well if I try to limbo.
Oh my gosh, wait, next 3D I should try to limbo.
I should try.
What?
I forgot to talk about something else.
that's my train of thought is maybe too obvious but but nimi
brought it up yesterday too how how me her and phoebe we all
hung out um but where that's where i was last week
yeah oh my gosh i i it was it was so really what I needed of
like just that kind of little break and just like hanging
out with my friends like that it felt so good was this your
first time you met Nimmy in person it was yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Nimmy spilled yesterday she did I
wasn't gonna say anything but yeah it was my first time
meeting her not my first time meeting Phoebe but also Phoebe
and I hang out outside of like a like a convention um
environment so it was my first time being able to like hang
out with Phoebe and like uh go do stuff together we did oh
my gosh it was Nimmy and I's I'm not gonna go too much in
this into into stories but it was Nimmy and I's first ever
escape room oh my gosh I feel like I was missing out I feel
like I was missing out of like of the escape room hype it
was so awesome and so what we were gonna do is we were gonna
go for like the theme that we liked the most but then they
kept selling out and the only like the time slots that we
could make it to and oh and the only one left was the nine
out of ten most difficult real and you know what We, one
minute, 40 seconds left to spare.
We made it out, baby!
Yeah!
Our first ever, and it was Phoebe's second escape room ever.
We, like, we, like, seriously, especially Phoebe.
Phoebe brained like crazy.
But, like, we were like, we're gamers, and we've done stuff
like, you know, like, room well actually it was funny nimi
was like you play those point and click games minto and i
was like yeah with a guy with a guide but yeah it felt like
it felt like i was like we play enough video games i think
we're fine we can we got this and we did it was crazy with
one minute and 40 i mean we we did use some hints but that's
okay it was our first one ever
and yeah oh I was happy too because I learned I did not know
this is that sometimes with escape rooms they will pair you
with random people they're not gonna make it they're not
gonna make it they made it yeah sometimes they'll pair you
with random people if they want like the room to be full and
luckily it was just the three of us because the room was not
very big i was like we would be on top of these other people
if we were trying to all be together i feel yeah so it was
just the three of us so we we actually all big brained all
by ourselves but at first two we were like maybe we would
want some other people because you know what if like we
don't know what we're room things like that imagine if you
ended up with an escape room otaku i was worried too what if
we got somebody that like kind of backseeded us or like
tried to take control we were all very good at like you know
delegating and being like okay i handled this and you try
this and you know it was really great so yeah it was really
good the chat experience iRL wake up little guy wake up It's
time to limbo.
You'll be late for the party.
Wake up.
Then you mutiny.
Yeah.
Would have been extra awkward if those randos were fans.
I don't think that...
I don't...
I think...
I mean...
Maybe Nimi.
I think I'd be okay.
I've never seen in the wild.
Look at him go!
Oh gosh.
Oh, can I?
Is there...
Oh.
Oh, yes there is.
There is a fall damage.
I learned.
Oh.
And also...
Oh, those are spikes!
I thought that was mud.
Oopsie.
Okay.
Jump!
I thought it was mud.
Oh, wait.
I want to be in black and white, too.
Wait.
Oh, I think...
Okay.
This is action.
Climb.
It's John Limbo.
Okay, good.
He does it all on his own.
I barely saw the spikes until they came into focus.
me neither it's so foggy how's the bit rate in this game i
was gonna become gray for this game but then i got all um
every uh my brain was so like ah the game's not working
we're okay now what do we do in here oh okay
this is good i stand out so much Actually, I feel like my
colors look pretty good against, like, a gray background,
you know?
Did he just check his watch?
Oh.
Uh.
Did I forget something?
Wait.
Oh, geez.
It's limbo clock.
Can I pull my boat?
Oh, okay, okay.
I have to remember the action button.
There we go.
Is this okay?
Be like a monkey?
Oh, yes.
It's so quiet.
It's like so loud and so quiet at the same time, you know?
This is getting scary.
So far, I'm feeling relaxed.
Yeah, I'm pretty good.
Wait!
Oh, um, can I jump over this?
Big leap!
Oh!
That's gnarly.
Let's see.
Yeah, some pretty weird grass, huh?
Good thing I caught it.
How do I...
Let's see.
Yeah, it's gnarly.
things gnarly not not not can I like oh he reached oh I saw
his little hands we come out stretched that scared me not
not not not and not gnarly oh my gosh cat's eye is the group
that made that gnarly song if you've ever heard it but they
made another song they released another song recently and I
don't like it it's called like internet girl they're like
haven't you heard I'm the internet girl but then they go eat
zucchini eat eat zucchini I'm like I'm like huh I mean I do
love me some zucchini I will eat zucchini
But...
I love zucchini.
Actually, I thought...
Sometimes I've mixed up zucchini and eggplant.
And I love zucchini, but I don't like eggplant.
What is that?
Oh, there's more spikes.
I don't know what that is.
Get up there.
Okay.
I might be a genius.
plant too wet i agree i agree i only got home and survived
my first bear pit wait what what does that mean i'm glad
butaku made it to final two yeah thanks for letting me put
my parody lyrics brain to work happy dubimintos i boo thank
you yeah butaku that's really good they're both so good
what's going on here do i crawl or huh the music is kind of
freaky oh sorry I tried to jump playing through OBS please
understand oh shoot ouch it's such a hairy rock Indiana
Jones okay
another one is there can you imagine is this a game it is it
is a game i'm glad i could get it working thank you guys so
much harry the rock johnson oh my gosh and then he take he
takes off he or he puts on his hat and he becomes parry the
rock johnson
wouldn't that be crazy ew smelly Can I swim?
Or do I not know how to do that?
I'm the captain and I go down with this ship.
Oh, I don't think I know how to swim.
Okay, good to know.
You will drown.
Oh, cool.
Thanks, guys.
Limbo was pretty popular back when it released.
I feel like...
Um...
that.
Oh, oops.
I was trying to jump and push it.
Big VTuber game back in 2018.
You mean YouTuber?
I mean, there were a few VTubers back then, but big indie
game back in the day.
Push!
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh, no!
No!
This kid has the lung capacity of an ant.
Come on.
Oh, no, no, no.
Please.
Am I going to die?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, maybe I don't.
Maybe I don't.
I'm not a genius.
But ants have good lung capacity.
They have the lung capacity of the size of an ant.
Um, actually, ants are great swimmers.
That's a terrible comparison, Minto.
Think, Minto, think.
I can't think.
I have to pee!
I mean, I'm gonna go to the little ghosty's room.
I'll be right back.
I'm sorry.
I have to go to the little ghosty's room.
I'll be right back.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
One second.
I have...
I have returned.
I have returned!
Hope she catch something nice.
Thanks.
Wishing hours fishing.
Okay.
Scatter!
No!
Don't leave!
Guys, this one's perplexing me.
Do I grab onto it and swim?
Nope.
Did you wash?
I always do?
Like, he just laid down with his fate.
Take the box to the rope.
Like, grab and push.
That's what I tried doing.
But she just died.
He gets two.
He takes one little step into the water.
He's like, I can't do it.
I can't do it.
Someone said, take it to the rope.
But, like, huh?
What rope?
This one over here?
I feel like that's kind of...
Like this.
You know, I did see this, but I didn't think it was
anything.
Oh no, the platforming begins.
Oh gosh, okay.
I have to press just like a second early.
Oh my gosh.
Now that I think about it, can you I can, but I would not
say that I am a strong swimmer.
But if you push me in, I will not drown.
There's a special thing there.
Yes.
Pull yourself up.
Oh, exploration off the ground.
Altitude is attitude.
Dude.
Okay, nice.
Rip Eggie.
Sorry, Eggie.
Oh, thank goodness.
Thought I was gonna die.
Fall damage.
Okay.
Companion crate.
Maybe I could jump from here.
Thank you!
We fight it!
Yeah!
Let's get...
Oh.
Okay.
I will remember that.
Oh!
AAAAAAAAHHHHH!
Wowza!
Oh my gosh!
Very cool.
Um...
What around here?
Can I grab his arm.
Bring them spiders!
Nope.
Maybe if I...
Oh!
I think he...
We got a... We got... Okay.
Nice.
Wait.
Oh!
That was a little unfortunate.
Oopsie.
Okay.
Jump!
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Good job, kid.
All right, now push.
How?
That's a great question.
It was, like, right here.
Oh.
Hello.
Yeah, do your thing.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah!
Oh, do I have to do it again?
Okay, strike one.
He never learned.
Ah!
I never learned.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Caught you talking smack.
True, actually.
Literally.
Got karma immediately.
Okay, now run.
Run, run.
Leave, you fowl beast!
Good job, thank you!
Yeah!
Oh.
We're going in.
It's so hairy in here, no?
So hairy.
The aesthetic of this game is crazy.
Oh, those are...
Uh-oh.
Wait.
little tough to move.
Uh-oh.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
Like, it's over for me.
Wait, I'm still alive.
Oh, no, I'm not.
Yes, I am.
He's taking me?
Oh, he's gonna eat me.
He's... Frodo?
Oh, I have no Sam to help me.
They just really had to play that one up, huh?
Unless?
Oh, I can wiggle.
Come on.
Yes.
Something, it'll tear on something.
this is the definition of would you love me even if i were a
worm wiggle tuber oh oops i miss i thought he would jump
shorter amount than than what he did my bad mortis
oh my gosh he did it again i just wanted to be a little bit
closer
but i need like the momentum no thank you so much for the
redirect hello hello clumsy guy we're just we got i mean we
got silky feet um it just
yeah Thank you
so much for that gift.
Thank you, thank you.
Hoorah!
Oh, whoop!
My bad.
I should have said thank you so much for that gift.
Thank you.
Paperback, thank you so much for that gift!
Da!
That's a creepy sound.
Come on.
Did I miss?
Oh, oh, oh!
Also, Raymac, thank you so much for the gifted, too.
Oh, well, thank you so much for the 20!
Colvo, thank you.
The 50, thank you.
Thank you, thank you for the gifted.
Thank you all for the gift.
Oh, gosh.
I hate being a worm.
If I become a worm, don't love me.
Put me out of my misery.
Literally forgot I said I'd give 50 subs if I blew on.
the tail!
Okay, all right we gotta push it over this little hill, and
then we gotta hop away.
Hop, hop, hop, hop, hop, hop, oh, okay.
I knew it was gonna happen as soon as I saw the tree
starting to come down.
I was like, this is gonna be bad news, players for me.
Take off, take you!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, oh, oh, okay.
We could do this, we could do this.
We could do this.
Oh no no no no no.
Faster.
Faster maybe.
We could.
They just had to add the little element of suspense and...
Oh god.
Oh golly.
Oh golly me.
Oh geez.
Ah!
Get up.
Hopping away to safety.
Look at me.
What the?
Are you a real?
I didn't think so.
You!
Son of a gun.
We made it.
We're out of limbo.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice one.
Yes, nice one.
Oh, gosh.
There's a body back there.
I wasn't sure what to do.
I just let it happen.
It's a long time fandom you and Nimi.
It's awesome to hear that you all hung out and had fun
together.
So excited to see what you and Phoebe and Vicky
accomplished.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Wow!
Oh, there we go, nice.
Okay.
So it cracks, and I go back!
Oh, that was close.
That was so stinking close.
Okay.
From here, do I just do a leap of faith?
Uh...
Leap of faith!
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, jeez.
Okay, okay.
That's what was gonna happen.
Whoop.
Um, huh.
I think I just have to jump again, maybe?
Right after?
But to where?
Oh!
What?
Because it opens that up.
Oh, I heard the setting up these traps!
Right!
They need to get, like, in Minecraft's dot.
Yeah, the rock opens the platform, so I wonder if I can...
I don't feel like I can jump high enough, though.
Let's try.
Jump!
Ah, you apparently can.
Awesome.
God, that's such a low blow.
low blow.
This game is pissing me off.
Jump!
Oh, she okay.
Alright, nice.
The music is scary.
That was evil, wasn't it?
Not a...
spitter.
But acts like one.
We're running.
Hey you!
Well, we found our culprit.
Of who's...
Of who's setting up these traps.
I feel like this game is atmospheric version of I wanna be
the guy or cat Mario.
But I don't know that one.
What's that?
Oh!
Oh, it's on fire?
Is this a rage game?
It can't be.
Oh.
Oh, wait, but they have to go into the water, right?
Okay.
But he keeps throwing stuff at me.
This one's not as big.
I can go.
Hey, you!
Oh, there's two of them.
What the heck?
I'll get your ass.
I'll get your ass right now.
Come here.
Come here, punk.
Come here, punks.
Come on.
I'll square up.
I know action, but...
Oh, they're hanging people.
Wait a second.
Wait, I don't think I would hang out with these people.
Wait.
Wait, I think this might be bad.
Oh.
I knew that was going to happen.
Is he going to do it right now?
Yeah, he does it early.
Or...
Oh, sometimes it just works and sometimes not.
Oh my god.
What the hell?
He was still climbing up it!
It's automatic.
Okay, okay.
Is it something that I trigger or like is it this?
Nope.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, there's
a...
Did you
do?
There was a second one!
No!
Oh my gosh.
I can't duck in this game, so...
Oh my god, please.
I...
Trigger!
No one expects the second trap!
They're so thorough!
Evil!
Jigsaw level threat!
Literally, they're just like, we're gonna get you one way or
another.
Oh my gosh!
I don't know.
and then i just see my head is blocking it but he just set
up another trap over there okay run
you have to beat the game in less than five deaths for an
achievement well good thing we're not a hundred percenting
it this character can crouch no i can't I don't think so.
Only jump.
Zigzag.
Oh yeah, let's try.
Ah!
Let's try again.
Maybe?
It's too low.
Maybe...
Hold on.
I think it has to be pretty...
There we go.
There.
Wait, isn't it supposed to be?
Wait, I think maybe I can climb up this now.
I don't think I can go that way.
Hoey!
Always good to have a second trap.
Unless you have a bad memory.
Hoey!
They're gonna throw more fire tires at me.
Don't do it, please.
I'm friend!
I just... I don't even know why I'm here.
Oh my gosh!
It killed him!
Wait, uh, oh.
I thought it's gonna kill me!
Oh!
I was already drowning!
Can't you just let me die?
Uh, do I jump here?
No, I drown again.
Um, can I push this?
Yes.
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Grab it!
Okay, thank you.
Keep going!
The spiders are like way too realistic.
It's so scary, you know?
Oh no no no, wait.
Uh oh.
And... oh geez.
Wait, uh oh, wait.
Do I need him to...
Ha!
Oh my gosh, please!
Pull up!
Ehehe!
Please, please, please!
Oh.
Dang it, I was so close.
Oh, from the beginning?
In the beginning.
Hoi.
All right.
Mr. Spider, Mr. Spider.
I was saying that to myself just now.
Hoi.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Kill me.
Take it.
The jump is like a little slow sometimes, you know?
It's not like a crisp jump.
It's like a very slow.
So brutal with it, too, I know.
Yeah, it is weighty.
Yeah, it's very weighty jump.
Come on.
tap thank you hey oh thank goodness thank
goodness oh geez oh nice but this is gonna crush me wait is
it oh there goes there's gonna crush me
No, it's gonna crush him!
That kid got eight.
He got devoured.
Well, actually the spider doesn't even eat them.
He just kills to kill.
Like a psychopath.
This game is nightmare fuel.
It's quite...
If you're afraid of spiders, definitely cannot play this
game.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I learned.
I learned not to trust the bottom.
You're still at it?
Oh, he has one leg left.
One leg yet.
Wait, I think I need him though.
How are you alive?
Don't you dare.
Oh my gosh.
Did that get me?
Oh, it did.
Wow.
Oh, he could just knock me over and that kills me.
Okay, okay.
Uh, let's see.
It's tenacious, guys.
Yeah, for real.
It definitely...
Is that...
Oh.
Oh!
I got your arm.
Oh my god.
Just gonna roll your little body over.
Wait, how do I...
Can I jump on top of him?
Okay, yeah, good.
We're gonna push your body.
How could you?
It's survival of the fittest, baby.
Yeah!
Survive.
I want to take this and use it as like...
like a way to protect myself.
Like a hairy lemon.
So a lemon?
Hey, other kids!
You're gonna play nice.
Oh my god, there's a kid in prison.
Y'all right up there?
Why do they have this, like, Lord of the Fly society?
What's going on?
Spear?
Yeah.
Kiwi?
Yes.
Am I right in there?
Wait.
Whoa!
I don't know what I needed that for, but...
Oh, right here.
How do you feel about eating kiwi skin?
I do sometimes.
Honestly, kiwi is so delicious.
I used to be a big kiwi.
So, it really, I feel like I've been missing out on kiwi for
so long in my afterlife.
Because I would taste like the artificial, like, strawberry
kiwi flavor stuff.
And I would be like, I love strawberries.
But kiwis are disgusting because I don't like the taste of
the strawberry kiwi.
Strawberry kiwi flavoring.
And so I just thought I hated kiwi.
you know and then one day I was just like I think I read
that kiwi was well it's good for like helping you sleep to
eat like a kiwi a day and so at one point I was like you
know what I'll I had a lot of sorry a lot of uh uh trouble
sleeping and so I um was like I was desperate for was just
like i will try eating a kiwi a day and um and so then i was
just like wait this is actually so delicious what who lied
to me oh this is water can i go in this or am i gonna oh
okay good oh oh wait that's not it wait that doesn't seem it
seems a little concerning i'm gonna like look make myself a
little bit smaller and lower myself i'll put my arms down
even so that you guys can see more it looks safe what are
you oh take it oh oh i made it wait why did he do that
there's a guy over here hello it's a standoff um yeah i'm
looking at that trap wire what do you want me to do about it
yeah mind control spooky it looked like a parasite on his
head okay just wanted to see what happens if i go in can i
get out really fast oh no splattery can i take a body and
throw it in there Like this one?
No, no, no.
Come here.
Eat kiwi with the skin on.
Wait, what did you say?
Oh, no!
My body!
Oh, whoa!
Oh, wait, wait.
Wait, I'm surfing?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wee!
No, no, my body.
Okay.
What did you say?
Guys are talking about the fruit, not the tiny birds.
I was listening to her about Vin talking about devouring
their skin.
No.
Oh, there we go.
Nice and easy.
That guy really... Oh.
That's the thing.
So I have to avoid these.
Oh, do you hear them trying to get at my brain?
Um, unlucky for you, there's nothing in there.
Oh, is this one?
No.
You just surfed on a kid.
Great work.
This is why you're the best boss.
This looks like a button.
It wasn't a button, but, you know.
Uh-huh.
Oh gosh, that's fast.
Is the game blinking or am I inside?
There's like a, there's like a, like an effect that does
make it kind of flicker.
There's only Koharu in that skull of hers.
So true.
So, so true.
Yeah.
Unfortunately, this game...
The game has like extremely minimal settings.
So I can only control the brightness.
And that's about it.
So sorry if it bothers you.
I can unfortunately do nothing about it.
I have to like get in there.
Ah, I see.
Okay.
Watch this be the opposite.
Uh-huh.
I know your games.
Wait, is that the kid right there?
Is that the one that I've been following?
Oh!
Oh.
Wait, now they're chasing after me.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Oh, they're dying.
Why are they...
Why is everybody coming after me?
Why are they all like all these factions?
Freaky.
What is going on?
You think they know their own area?
Who built the traps?
Yeah, they don't even...
Maybe they got them mixed up.
Maybe they couldn't remember which one was the button one
and which one was the...
Was the sensor one, you know?
Where does this go?
Does it drop down?
Oh, that doesn't look very good.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, keep it going.
Keep going.
Don't stop.
This was a mobile game.
Seriously?
Is that old?
I don't know what this is for.
Oh.
Oh, it was...
I think for this...
This guy here...
I see.
Oh, that sucks.
Well, which do I do first?
This is my question.
And what is the cart for?
Think, Minky, think.
You're asking a lot of me, you know.
Now, this is a puzzle.
Yeah, this is a puzzle.
Does what this one it It's actually I feel quite fast So I
think this one would be the one that we do
Second Oh I'm just like
Maybe I jump on this and like kind of ride it
Because I can't pass through...
Oh, there we go.
Oh, whoops.
No, no, don't!
No!
Because I can't go through the spikes, I'll die.
I'll test it.
He just grazed them.
He just grazed them and was like, No, I'm out.
I'm out, I'm out.
I think we can get this to catapult me.
Maybe.
It's a very sharp saw.
Yeah, right?
Gently stroked by the gears.
It looks more like...
It looks like, um...
Oh my gosh, like a skincare device or something that I've
seen before.
Okay.
Yeah, some sort of derma roller.
Exactly!
Go, go, go!
Oh, shoot.
Gosh, you have to be really fast.
How am I supposed to make this launch, man?
Tie it to the cart.
Tie what to the cart?
wait like yeah because jumping on this it doesn't do I tie
yeah let's see the first this rope yeah because it gets
pretty long I don't even know you could tie in this game
what the heck kid oh my gosh I had it
hmm I
think I...
Oh gosh.
Oh, no!
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
It is quite precise.
Okay.
And...
Oh!
He's like, I always wanted to be a monkey.
This is my dream.
Need the strong way.
Where can I, where's the shop that I can upgrade my legs at?
Where's the shop at, huh?
Okay.
Wait.
Please, go up.
Ah, why does he let go?
it's okay I think it's me I'm pressing down it's me okay
that's my fault I think he's like scooting down I think I
just need to let it happen okay okay it's me it's me I'm the
problem I'm the problem it's my fault yeah I just hang on I
just gotta hang on the part of me wants to like Press down?
Because I'm like, yeah, you're pulling down.
It's me.
I'm the problem.
Okay, go, go up.
And jump.
Yes.
Okay, nice way.
Go, go, go, go!
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
Dang it.
We
died.
My bad.
Ah!
We have the idea, though.
I just have to execute it properly.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
We need this here first.
Nope.
Please move.
We need you down here.
Nah.
Stay.
Okay.
Almost there, yeah.
We have the idea.
Okay.
You get quite a long time with the first...
one yeah i think the pit is there for a reset what if you're
just like i'll do it what i feel like this doesn't really
need a reset all you can do is pull two stuff so okay wait
wait wait oh my god he didn't jump high enough you little
sucker get this kid in boy scouts He's got no muscle mass.
Okay.
I wish I could do, um, like a safe state right here.
Go,
go, go!
Okay.
Yeah, we did it.
Yeah!
Gross, gross, gross!
What is this?
Oh, a little frog.
Why is it so stinky?
Ooh.
Wait, is this the possession?
Yeah.
Oh, wow, wait, I can't...
Wow, wait, this is so cool.
Oh, I can jump though.
I can jump.
Possessed me.
Possessed me to go into the right direction.
Oh, let's go.
Wait, I'm possessed, but I'm like still controlling it.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
No!
He's gonna lead!
Why did it, why did it wanted me to die?
Huh.
Brainworm.
I can't fight my brainworms.
you guys.
So it like short circuits and then
I control him for a bit.
What if I stop here?
What if I let him?
Wait, no, no, no, turn around.
Maybe if I just keep running.
No, he's short circuits here.
But I can kind of help facilitate how slow you go.
So maybe they'll eat him.
Ah, yeah!
There we go.
Awesome.
Oh, it's the sunlight that causes them to activate.
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, yeah.
Cool.
Okay.
you want that little buddy you want that buddy I'll get that
for you
somehow count on me watch I give it to him and he turns into
like this horrifying worst creature ever
he's gonna be like yes you gave me the mushrooms that turned
me evil Yes, it's my favorite snack.
The mushrooms that turned me evil.
What's this?
Cool.
Okay.
Oh, here's a rope right here.
Or sometimes I can't tell if something's in the foreground
or the background, you know.
Hoi!
He scrambled over.
Did you get what you wanted, buddy?
Gotcha!
Oh!
Almost.
I almost had a pet.
I almost had you, my sweet.
Wait, that's in the background.
Depth perception.
Sometimes it's hard to tell in this game, though.
Ha!
I chase you.
And you fall in there.
Oh!
He's a hamster!
We're powering...
The city?
One single gerbil is powering the whole city.
Insane.
I think we need to let the water flow maybe.
and fill this up, yeah.
But I can't swim.
How does that benefit me?
Oh, there's a log!
And there's...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wow.
Okay, okay.
I gotta be fast.
Hump the power.
Oi!
I can't swim.
There's like this, that pole, like on the...
Huh.
Let's see.
There's this right here.
I wonder if I...
Use it somehow.
Oh, it's just to get me in and out.
Huh.
Hampto.
Oh!
Why is the log on this side?
Wait a second.
I didn't...
Oh,
okay.
I gotta put it like...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I get it.
That's so funny.
That was so weird.
I can't even see it on the ground, I'll be honest.
Oh, I can see it on the ground.
We'll put you like right here.
That should be good, maybe?
The game was like, hey, dummy.
He dies after like three seconds of no air.
I know, he's just a baby.
Okay, a one and a two and a...
Oh, so close.
So close.
So close!
Yeah, so far.
Your new name should be Minto's maggots.
Ew!
That's gross.
Or ghost brain worms.
Oh,
close.
Oh, wait, oh, just just just kidding just kidding i wanted
to see if i could swing but it just kicks me off so all
right all right a one and a two and a wait run run run run
run run run run run run run yeah we're so powerful
okay oh rain asmr is this dangerous for me the sludge Yeah.
I'm just checking.
I don't like this.
I don't like this one bit.
Can I stop it?
Can I plug it up?
Hmm.
Let's see what's going on in here.
Okay.
And then there's a ladder And a bunch of spikes Huh I think
I need to plug it up So that the water starts You know There
we go Oh, oh, okay, okay We're going, we're going, we're
going
Uh, what does this do?
Oh, I need to put my bucket over here!
Wait, wait, wait!
Oh, no, I mean, not my bucket.
My crate!
Okay, okay, okay, I got it.
I got it, I got it, okay.
Wait, where is it?
My crate!
Crate, oh crate, where are you?
There you are.
Companion Cube.
She kicked the bucket.
I don't know, okay.
When I was, when I first saw this puzzle,
I thought that this lever was a crutch.
Like, you know, have you ever needed crutches before?
Oh my gosh.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh gosh, that was close.
It does look like it.
It does, right?
So I thought.
Hoa!
Nice.
Gaming?
Wait, does this keep rising?
Or...
Um...
Uh, it absolutely does.
Oh, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Ah!
I caught on a pixel!
Oh!
No kidding.
Wow.
I got caught on a pixel.
That's really unfortunate.
Go, go, go, go.
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come.
Pixel imperfect.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
My dummy ass.
in a limbo?
I don't know.
I'm not very flexible at all.
You would think because of my ectoplasm, like, it'd be fine,
but I am unfortunately not so flexible.
We'll go a little bit more just for good measure, okay?
La la la la la.
Okay, good.
I was gonna say my thing is too heavy!
Oh gosh, wait.
What's going on here?
Ah!
No, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
Okay, good.
Is this still rising?
No, okay.
And jump!
Oh!
Nice.
Great checkpoint.
Yeah, the game is very generous with the checkpoints at
least, so...
I will be thankful for that at the very least.
What the...
What was that?
Starting to get hungry, guys.
Oh, the water is rising.
Water is rising.
Something getting low.
Hold on.
I want to check.
Okay.
Ah, okay.
So there's that balloon thing.
Which I think we use right here?
Perhaps.
Not quite sure.
I have some croquettes I bought.
I'm gonna eat those.
The buoy.
Oh, is it because I'm on it?
Wait, did I just ruin that?
Wait.
Oh, no, I need to pull it!
I'm a dummy dumb, sorry.
Just kill me.
Me!
Thank you so much for the tiny kitten!
Thank you!
I thought it was going to break it for some reason.
And then...
And then I stand on it?
Oh.
Like, over here?
I use it?
Come here, come here.
Come on, oh, let me jump on-
This one's tricky.
like it feel like i oh no why'd you do that i feel like i
need it to wait i guess i could just oh but i need to push
it over here no right i'm not sure how to get it over there
without avoiding the water yeah that's how i feel
unless for some reason it comes over here on its own maybe
it's designed to do that it is not
I'm not done with that door oh okay I think I get it then
when it jumps up I close it right oh stop doing that so I it
whoa whoa whoa my bad it does the bounce and then I close it
real fast right okay and there we go okay then I push it
over into here, and then I run.
And then I go up here.
Hoi!
Ami!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Or welcome too!
Wait.
Yeah.
Or, no?
Ah, ah!
Ah, I see!
Oh, interesting.
Just, like, Stinky, minky, limbo boy, allergic to bath.
What are you talking about?
I'm not allergic to bath.
Oh, but there's a lever here.
What does that do?
Oh, okay.
Minty fresh at all times.
Exactly.
Ooh, okay.
Whoa.
Oh, now I can't make it.
Oh,
okay.
Oh, geez.
Where am I going?
Nowhere.
Okay.
Actual puzzle time.
Oh.
maybe like that's enough
bro doesn't even attempt i know there's not even like a
flailing of the arms he's just literally like
no give this kid i swear
i don't even know if like me doing that is doing anything.
Literally gives up.
Like, you've come this far and you're just gonna give up.
Oh.
You're just gonna give up.
You've come this far.
He's like, I can take...
I can take factions trying to kill me.
I can take spiders.
I can take brain worms.
but a little bit of water is too much for me.
Hold on, I'm going to grab my croquettes.
They're literally right here, so.
Oh, no, I don't have a like a chopstick or fork or anything,
though.
Do you guys mind if I go grab one real quick?
My croquette.
I'll be right back.
What kind did you get?
They're just like a veggie.
I'll be rebuke I'm hungry I'll be rebuke
fast so fast Wow Minto is so fast she never keeps us waiting
for too long she just does it instantly how does she do it
she's zooming you if you saw that way I looked, I'm like
running like Bigfoot to get to the kitchen and back.
Big steps.
They were warm earlier.
Now they're a little bushy.
And the condensation got on my dress.
And now it's touching me.
It's cold.
You want to warm them up?
I would have to put them in, like, a air fryer or something
to make them actually kind of toasty again, you know, so.
It's okay, though.
Yummy.
It's not grease, it's the water.
Mmm.
Yummy.
Mmm, fried goodness.
Okie dokie.
Let's get back to it, folks.
Hmm.
My head is blocking part of this.
Hold on.
I'll go here.
She has such a tiny head.
Boy, I feel like I have a big head because I'm blocking
stuff.
Food that keeps you hydrated and full.
We're speed running.
Hydration and food.
Let's go.
Whoa!
No.
I mean, I feel like I have to use the little block, but...
Whoa!
Two levers.
Oh wait, right.
So maybe.
Oh, wait.
Oh, because we don't want to distribute the water to the
other side.
We want to keep it here.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We don't want to push it over there.
Oops, my bad.
Wait, did that...
Oh, I messed up.
My bad.
Wait.
Uh, I checked my day.
Um, I messed up.
Uh.
Ah!
Wait!
We can fix this, I just gotta go back and then do it all
over again.
Actually?
Just die.
.
Wait.
Hold on, let's try it.
Let's try it.
The worst they can say is no.
Oh, yeah.
See, this seems doable.
Yeah!
Are these brain worms?
Squish.
squash oh you want to possess my brain you want to wiggle on
in through my ears and start munching and crunching actually
i guess you wouldn't crunch at my brain it's quite soft and
squishy you want to get in there you want to squeeze your
way through my brain lines oh i'm possessed where am i going
into the water with the other worms let's see can i grab
this before he possesses me
uh-huh if i push this down here oh i cannot push it down
okay just kidding can i get up there and grab him oh oh
wait I think I messed up no don't do it don't do it kid
don't do it
it just rockets out yeah it's pretty it's pretty sick pretty
icky I
feel like this but oh
he made it really easy for him I feel like it won't...
Oh, I did it again, but...
It doesn't change control unless it's in the sunlight.
Hooray!
No!
That's not the name!
Stop it!
Your eye blues!
Well, there is sunlight back where we can.
Up there, that's right.
If I use the box to jump...
Oh!
I missed... Oh, come on!
Die,
die, die, die, die.
Okay.
Oh, why is you messing up now?
Die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die.
Okay.
Maybe Winnie's facing that way.
All right, there we go.
Okay, okay.
Oh, that's not why I went.
There we go.
Okay.
All right.
We need this.
all the way to the edge.
Take...
Possess me!
Okay.
Control!
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Alrighty.
Is that a ladder I can take or...
I sure hope so.
Okay, good.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Alright, we're going up.
We're going up!
Boop, boop!
Oh,
this part's a pain in my side.
Don't do it.
There we go.
Oh.
You're doing good, though.
You got this.
Thank you!
I got my own little brain buddy.
That's my brain buddy.
He makes me go a little sideways.
I always wanted a brain buddy.
Do I have to wait?
I think it's okay now.
Here's my brain buddy.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Oh, wait.
Where do I go from here?
Wait.
Uh.
Oh, the water's getting higher?
Where do I go from here?
If I go to...
Oh, is it gonna spit out something that I can use to float
on?
Uh-huh.
Wait, I see it!
I see it!
Yes, it does!
Wait, why can't I jump?
Oh, wait, I can only go to the left!
Wait, is...
No!
No, you stupid kid!
Ah!
Oh my gosh, okay.
Oh, what a place to put me back in, huh?
Can I go...
Oh, geez, okay.
Oh, what?
Maybe I can go.
Can I get the box at least?
No, I can't do anything.
Limbo.
This is the key where you launch arrows at your arms and
legs.
Can I put the...
Be on the side of your car?
Of course, I'd be honored.
There's a light there, though.
Oh, I guess...
Okay, we have to be speed.
Because we have to get back to the light while it's rising.
Super fast.
Hoi!
Okay.
Now we wait.
Now we are patient.
Cachow?
Cachow.
Oh, and they're going to eat them.
They're going to...
I see them up there.
The little guys.
Okay, now I have to wait and not walk into the spikes.
It is once again us being patient.
And go.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, God.
Eat it.
Nice.
Yay!
We regain control.
Oh, um...
Oh, is this still rising?
Not really.
Oh, but I guess I can't go over that way.
Onwards.
But I want to see what's over here.
Am I the only curious one?
Is it just me?
I love these Minecraft fall into the water, you're fine.
Wait!
Okay, I give up.
I give up, I give up, I give up.
Onwards and upwards.
Oh, that was a big jump.
Are we gonna find nice people?
A town!
Huh!
Literally gives up.
Oh,
they, it's a fake out.
They make you think it's gonna fall.
Oh!
No!
Give me an H!
I thought I was...
I feel like I'm supposed to jump up on the...
Okay.
Crazy.
Sound effects.
A-T-O-T-T-O!
That's okay.
Can I climb the H?
Oh, jeez.
H-O-T-T.
Oh, gosh.
I just have to keep...
I have to run and run and run.
Run and run.
Oh, I thought it would.
Okay.
So close.
Oh, Jiao.
You can take me hard to go.
Oh, I think I'm not going to make it.
I'm not gonna make it!
Oh, she made it!
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, no, no, why did I do that?
I overcorrected too hard.
What people do when they drive cars even?
Oh, wait, I wasn't ready.
My bad.
They overcorrect.
Three, two, one.
Hoi!
What the E does...
eventually right okay I do see the string okay actually I
think I was supposed to fall
you're supposed to fall and grab the string I think and then
swing to the other side okay alright one two three hoi oh I
was too late that's okay maybe
oh too late that's okay though it's not okay You have to be
so...
One, two, three.
Hoi!
Okay.
That's better.
I think I go from the O.
Yeah!
There we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Yeah!
You can yell at me too if I'm in the way of you guys seeing
some of the puzzles.
and scoots around easy.
Acing it.
I might be a gamer.
I might be a bit of a gamer.
This L is gonna break.
Hoi!
Nice.
You are perfect place, Minto.
Thank you.
Your Honor.
Oh, whoa.
she's a gamer oh wow cool oh not cool interesting does this
lead to anywhere dead all right what do we wait stop stop
stop nice do I keep going or do I break this.
Uh, whoops!
Oh.
They break it themselves.
My reflex is unmatched.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
We're fine.
Oh, no!
I see another worm!
What's over here?
Alright!
I love get crushed simulator.
Woo!
Yeah, I love getting crushed.
I'm eating some more.
I've never had this place as croquettes before, but they're
delicious.
So we remember the sunlight is here, everybody.
The sunlight.
Sunlight.
Come here, little brain worm.
Are you gonna make me think about Snake and Ocelot again?
Oh, Lolli Lolli Lolli Lolli Lolli Lolli.
Oh, I get it.
I had to do that.
I didn't even think about it, but I would have gotten
crushed by the thing if I hadn't done this before, like done
it first, so good thing.
We would have gotten crushed and died.
That's how much of a genius I am.
things without even thinking.
No one needs to make.
It's true.
I'll just think of it all on my own.
Almost every night.
I think it's funny that some people think that maybe I only
like Metal Gear because of Yowie.
But that's not even the case.
I feel like maybe Yowie is like...
Like it's fun.
like in Metal Gear for me, but it might even be like one of
the least reasons that I like it.
Yeah, it's like a bonus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I actually like it for the plot.
Average, average visual novel fan.
I like it for the plot, I promise.
This is a lot.
How far am I going?
Wait, this looks like a button.
We jump.
Wait, I could have played crane game.
Oh, no, I'm about to walk into my death.
Oh, okay.
This is where we stop.
Okay, cool.
Press the button.
Wait.
Oh.
Um.
It went.
It weighs, it's like a, as light as a feather.
Well now, oh, I think I need it to jump over the spikes.
The saw.
Oh, oops.
Yes.
Oops.
We're okay.
We're gamers.
Oh, why did I run?
Oh, that made me jump.
Eat up!
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, one second, please.
I take more bite.
Yummy, yummy.
Brainworm.
Oh, who would have thunked that and killed me?
Run!
Okay.
Let's go.
Is this as far down as it gets?
Okay.
We can make it.
Maybe.
Not.
Maybe not.
Has to check every way to die in the game.
Hey, go back up.
Go back up.
Go back up!
It does kind of twist, or not twist, uh, yeah, yeah.
It kind of bobs up and down, so.
Wait!
Seriously?
He just, yeah!
Can it swing?
Let's try that.
Good idea.
Doesn't seem like it.
From one person to another with a stutter, thank you for
changing the name.
from Whispy.
You're welcome.
The thing about it being a seesaw, though, is it doesn't
really like go...
It's not that dramatic of a...
Maybe we really gotta shake it up.
Oh, that's good, that's good!
Hoi!
Give it time.
Yeah, we are eyeball.
Like eyeball.
But Instead, boo.
It did look higher, no?
Like, around here, it stops moving.
We gotta give it good momentum.
Here we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, here we go.
This is it.
This is the run.
Nice.
Okay.
Good job, team.
And then we got to do the same here.
I think?
The ghost is playing Wimbo.
Play inside?
Is that a sequel?
Maybe.
I can't tell if I'm really doing anything here.
Okay.
Closer.
There we go.
Push forward.
Go, go, go, go.
Go back.
Push forward.
I feel like I can make that, but I don't...
Pull the hand.
Oh my god, there's a handle!
Sorry, I really...
I didn't see it at all.
I'm so sorry.
Here I am, just...
I'm...
Completely manual.
Yeah.
Alright, we're back here now.
We got all this stuff going on.
There was a, uh, this, yeah, this crate I noticed earlier.
Whisp is our maiden name.
Before the red dress?
What is that supposed to be?
Before the red dress.
You guys are silly.
Um,
can I make that?
Um...
that'll happen a puzzle will be so simple that you can
overcomplicate it well it's because the other one required
me to run back and forth i just figured oh yeah it'll make
me do that again you know so that's why i thought i
will make a post on both twitter and youtube
oh that's so funny i didn't realize that i only saw his arms
stretched out and that's why i oh wait uh wait go go up go
that's how i knew that i could press i was like figuring out
or i was like oh i feel like i should be able to press this
but wait stop stop it stop it thank you now we need to swing
it i feel like for some reason oh oh oh gosh wait
Is there something that we need to get to?
Let's, we'll go over this way for the, for the, in the
meantime, we'll check this out over here.
What do we have going on?
A lever, a mysterious lever?
Nazo no lever.
What does this do?
Okay.
Nazo no car no joke.
Why do you know that?
Why do you know that, series, huh?
Wait!
Oh, uh, can't I just push it off?
Don't fall, don't fall!
Okay.
Might not hurt the pin.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, I could pin it and shot it.
One second.
Oh, gosh.
Let's see.
Okay, hold on.
Thank you so much for the fire content.
Thank you!
Thank you.
I'm too, I'm not heavy enough.
I'm too small.
I'm just a bag.
I'm like a scaly man.
But I can't reach this guy.
I need him.
The elevator?
Wait, the elevator.
something you will need to get the box out of that spot.
This, wait, it'll have something?
Oh no, not that one.
Up?
Hopefully just, oh okay, that's as far up as it goes.
Does it go any further down?
Crayon, thank you so much for not buying it, thank you!
Maybe I have to swing it here?
No.
Let's grab my box.
No, not up.
No, just turn it off!
No!
Ah, man.
Oh gosh, sorry, hold on, my nose.
It's so itchy!
I'm thinking, I'm thinking!
Hold on!
I can think about it, my nose!
One second.
Oh my god.
It's so...
It's...
Ugh.
Okay.
I'm okay!
But still no sneeze.
Sorry.
I don't know!
Okay, I want a hint.
I want a hint.
Grab something that is in the elevator.
The only thing I can grab is a handle.
Yeah, I know the platform has a handle.
Doesn't swing very far.
Unless I... Oh!
I did it again.
On top of the elevator.
On top.
There we go.
Okay, now I make it go back down.
Upper.
How do you see that?
Up there?
There's something there?
I don't even see.
Oh, look.
Okay.
Sorry.
I need the, I think I need the box to get up there.
What is, what, I don't even know what I'm getting up there
though.
I think.
Oh wait.
Ah.
Get on top.
And jump.
Actually.
Oh wait.
I see the rope up there.
Can I climb anything here?
Hold?
Oh wait, do I need to...
Ah!
Okay, okay, wait, I have to be speed.
I have to be super fast.
Okay.
And jump!
Whoa!
Is that an Easter egg?
Or...
Was that something?
like I need it or is that an easter egg?
Am I gonna fall to my death?
Yes.
Take it.
Wait, do I have to redo it?
No!
It's just a secret.
Well, I got it.
Why did you guys tell me to go up there then?
Ah!
Is there another box up left?
No?
There isn't.
Nothing else.
I feel like I need to swing it to where it goes pew and then
like slides upwards, you know.
Why does he look so cute?
What did that mean, huh?
Very close.
Some way to make the chains longer.
Yeah, because it doesn't swing very much at all.
But only way to make it chains longer is like this.
But it doesn't, like, stop.
It only just, it goes.
Like, I can't.
No, no, no, come back.
I don't like this puzzle.
One second.
Okay.
I was making sure that I was like, Whenever I get pinged,
I'm like...
Yes.
Am I missing something?
Pull it onto the platform as it's going down.
You can do that!
Wait, you can do that!
Aww, what the hell?
What?
You can just do that!
Oh, don't push it back.
Oh my god!
I wouldn't have thought of that at all.
I don't even think you could do that.
What the heck?
Oh my god.
What?
I feel like that's crazy brained.
Wow!
Oh my gosh.
As chat said, handle.
I thought that's not...
That doesn't be... I was trying to...
Use the handle to push it and swing it.
That was like super brained.
I don't know.
I wouldn't.
Even if you say handle, I'm not thinking of that.
What the?
Why did he grab it over his head like that?
Actually, where do you go from here?
Maybe I swing to somewhere?
But to where?
Oh.
I wasn't supposed to go up, was I?
Eh.
Ugh.
The lever?
If I...
Do that...
Aha!
Oh gosh, oh gosh!
Jump, jump, jump, jump!
Jump, jump!
Wait, my box is too far.
Okay.
Come back down, please.
Ugh.
No!
Oh, why am I a child?
Oh, grow up already, kid.
Grow up.
It's a harsh, harsh world.
Come on.
Oh, my God.
I try.
Okay.
Just a little over.
He hasn't eaten in God knows how long.
I think it's his fault he's here.
Why?
What's he doing?
What's this kid doing here?
Oh, we got him.
We got him!
Yeah!
How far does this go anyway?
Where are we going?
Oh, okay.
I do need to go down to that lever over there.
It's not letting me swing!
Okay, good.
I was like, please don't break your legs.
Uh-huh.
Oh, I don't...
Oh.
I think I see what's going on here.
Maybe?
Oh, wait, I don't think I can...
We're a little shorter than I thought we would be.
This looks safe, yes.
This is the world's safest factory ever.
Ever, ever, ever.
Oh, wait, I think I know what to do.
Wait.
Do I may have to make them stack?
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Um.
So we need to release this one.
The one on the left foot.
Or, yeah, it would be easiest.
The one on the left first.
This timing seems kind of crazy.
That should give me some time.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Oh shoot, sometimes physics.
Oh, don't get crushed.
Oh, I pressed it too late.
Okay, all right, all right, all right.
Oh, uh.
Okay, I push the other button too soon.
It's spinning backwards.
Don't look at it.
Don't think about it.
Okay, three, two, one.
Oh my gosh.
Push, push, push, push, push.
I had the timing so good before.
What happened?
Somehow I had the timing so well.
Okay, what I also have to worry about is the saw eventually
starts coming, so...
Okay, um...
Wait like five seconds.
Yeah, I know.
One, two, three, four, five.
Okay.
Oh, but I have to jump over it.
Oh!
Wait!
Ah!
Oh, this game gets tricky!
You, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you, you.
Oh my gosh.
that's true i don't need well i think it'd be easier well
yes i have to stack them in that order because the saw oh
whoa uh three two one i think actually it'd be better for me
to pull it
oh oh oh oh
the toes literally got my toes this kid can't stand in two
inches of water but but his toes are gone and he's just like
ouch all right yeah it's just the timing okay four three two
one brum
oh the
other one was not so difficult okay oh five four three two
one
oh Oh, please, please.
It was so perfect.
He just wouldn't climb up.
I think I pressed it too early, but that's...
Let's just try it.
Donk.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Oh, my god.
I was trying to get to the other side, but, you know.
Four, three, two, one.
Okay.
Oh my god, no!
You stupid kid!
Four, three, two, one.
I think it's too difficult to push, like, the timing.
Oh, wait, why did I wait so long?
I was getting distracted.
It just... It just bounces right off.
It just bounces right off!
Three, two, one.
Okay, now get on top.
And good!
Yeah!
What was that?
Any drowns?
Wait, what am, what is happening?
I'm avoiding every...
Oh!
Beneath the Arthropod.
Oh.
I was gaming.
Don't look up.
Gamers don't look up.
Cool secret.
All right, what's going on in here?
How much of the game do I have left?
Are you friend?
What do you do?
You're just a bug.
Can you carry me up there?
Fourth of the way.
Might not be able to beat it today, then.
That's okay though.
Less than half.
It's okay.
Hmm.
Trying to like sneak up on it, but I don't think there's a
way.
Huh?
Can I grab anything here?
Would you like a little foot?
Would you like my toes as well?
Let's see, I can't tell of motion thing or oh oh he goes
back okay okay okay
slow and steady
jump on your back no why did you watch his little arms he
was just like please please my noggin is blockier there i'll
move over just a tad again All right.
Go back down.
Okay.
I think I have to grab them rather than jump on them.
Start buzzing.
Dang it!
What the?
You.
Oh.
Okay.
We cannot crouch.
I don't think it was the distance because our arms didn't go
out.
Yeah, we can't...
I think I have to from here...
I have to attempt...
I can't even jump that far though.
If there's...
I don't think there's a walk.
It's just move or jump.
Very simple.
Okay, I'm gonna, once I get to the edge of the water, I'm
gonna run at him and grab him.
Three, two, one.
Gamerage, gamer rage, gamer rage, gamer rage.
Okay.
Yeah, if only there were a box, I know.
This is the worst kind of thing.
stealth this is kind of gameplay that i like dislike it
forces you to be so slow you know and then when you have to
redo it it's very like
very you know it's just one of those annoying like
what the hell
i couldn't grab his little legs i tried
I think if I tap again I think if I tap again he's gonna
he's gonna run you know
yeah I knew it I knew it I knew it all it was was a tap you
guys all I did was a tap I did get closer than I ever had
before but I wasn't ready for him to jump so I should have
been
Oh, I hate this.
This part sucks.
Because I don't know if I grab his legs or if I, like, you
know, use the action button.
Or if, like, because, you know, when he grabs ropes, it's
not really, like, uh, I don't have to grab it with the
button.
I think.
No, I definitely need to grab his legs because the little
guy's arm reaches out for it.
Oh, man.
like it's it's just annoying though
yeah it looks like I need to use the button because he
reaches out like it's a little character animation you know
it just is annoying it's really annoying
nope nope if I just run it doesn't do anything it's not I
can hold the button it doesn't do anything
Don't look at me I'm literally flicking The controller
I got his butt Yeah Yeah I'm not letting go I got here I'm
not letting go You can't make me Oh well I could do that And
that would That would cut Yeah Yeah That would cause me to
have to let go, yeah.
Oh, we made it.
Oh.
Whoa, freaky.
Have a great day today.
Thank you!
Sure got a leg up on him.
What's the point of having to open that, I wonder?
Okay.
Where...
Where does this go?
Whoa, what is this?
Oh, okay.
What does this do?
Okay.
What does it do?
What are we...
Oh, no.
Oh.
Oh, I guess we're making tires now.
Oh,
wow.
That's pretty fast.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, geez.
Arruga.
Oh, but...
Okay.
Oh?
Wait.
Uh, you can make it!
Skinny legend!
There you go!
Me too is as cute as ever I see!
Oh, my!
Arruga!
Okay, wait, can I... Oh, wait, wait, boop, boop, boop!
I think I did it.
That did something.
Arruga!
Nice and smooth.
But what?
Where did it land?
Over here?
Ah!
Oh!
Okay.
Hmm.
Big donut.
What else do we have?
Whoa!
Battle gear.
Okay.
Yeah, it does not give much time at all.
What the...
I'm wondering if we can, like, stop the thing from...
from closing?
I don't even...
But why?
You know what I mean?
Like, why am I... Oh, because I want that down!
Okay, this one doesn't move.
Okay.
So maybe we want that down here.
Oh, probably so that I can get that lever.
Okay, okay, okay.
But why?
Alright, so if I...
Let her rip?
Did I kill me?
No.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, I don't have much time, then.
Ah!
Run, run, run, run, run!
I was attempting to just stand on the ledge so that when it
opened up, I could grab it and pull it, but since it knocked
me off, um, that's why...
Okay.
But I think I have enough time because I... That's why...
Because when I tried this, yeah, it doesn't let you stand
there.
So...
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Push it to the left instead?
I guess maybe I would have more...
Oh, if I have more...
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run!
Wait, but...
Well, I guess it'll still roll.
It'll still roll.
Okay, here we go.
Wait!
No!
Wait, did that kill me?
It tapped my head!
No, kidding.
Okay, wait.
It literally just bonked me.
Barely.
Yeah, I just grazed it for real.
It's crazy.
Okay, fine.
I'll pull it first, and then I'll get on top, and then I'll
push it over.
So needy.
Softest video game protagonist ever.
He's like, I'm Timmy, and I'm five years old.
My cranium is still growing.
It has not hardened to max capacity yet.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, nice.
Tim, you have something.
0.3 HP.
Here we go.
Pulling another lever.
I love pulling those and not knowing what's going to happen.
Look at.
He's just looking around like, Did I do that?
Very cool, Timmy.
Good job.
Pull the lever, cronk.
Yes.
That one.
You pulled the correct lever, cronk.
You did it.
Wait, did I...
have to do that or did i choose wait did i go the fancy way
what does this do
oh oh interesting how high does it go
oh then what
wait do i need my box wait i don't oh wait do i pull oh did
i push the box onto that yes we need the box okay my box
need two box wait I need two
so do I need to go get my box from over here do I need this
guy too you're coming with me
yep me too I'll meet you there I'll meet you there
Yep See you on the other side, buddy
Whoa, you broke my fall Awesome
No, no, no, no Get back down, you Yes, yes, there you go
Okay
Now you You
Okay Now, I'm not quite sure.
I feel like if I put this here, well, I have enough time to
do everything.
Or do I...
Nope, not at all.
World's slowest climber.
Okay, so what we do is we push this on here.
And we jump here.
Got it.
She pulled on my lever to, like, wrong.
What happens when you do that?
Oh!
I really wish I had known that.
Wait, are you gonna come back?
And death and die and suffer and never see the sunlight
again!
What if I just swing myself?
What if I don't even press it?
Oh!
Oh wait, hold on, I think the girlies are asking for me.
Uh, uh, yes.
If you guys are good with it.
Um, and then also, uh, hold on.
I'm sending things to Vicky.
Um, where is my stuff anyway?
All here?
No.
I have a folder for all of my stuff and now I can't find it.
Where is it?
Huh?
Where are you?
What the heck?
Maybe under here.
No?
I have a folder for all of my stuff.
Now I can't find it.
It's kind of...
Great song, Winto.
Thank you!
Oh!
It's because...
The window was like...
The window was cut off because I moved it off the screen.
So...
Oh, here's my...
Okay, there we go.
Alright, I sent things.
I'll just periodically check to see if they need me before
the collab today, you know?
Maybe I...
Grab it on the way back and I do a big swing.
Oh, that was so weak.
That was so weak!
You're this stupid kid!
I wish I could...
swing so hard that I can press this again.
He's just a little guy.
Five years old.
I don't even know that.
I made that up.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot.
Can I grab it?
Yes!
She's a genius!
Oh!
Oh, okay, we're fine.
Oh,
I think everything is turning.
Wait a second.
That doesn't seem very good.
Wait.
Um.
Oh, the world is one big giant wheel.
It's one big battle gear.
Oh, is it still turning?
Oh, gosh.
Uh, Yolo.
Oh, man.
Okay.
not quite sure what i do here but
because it turns that way so it's not like i can use the key
it can run on the gears or anything but it does seem like it
stops so i'll just wait till it's for it to stop drink some
of my tea in the meantime
oh no
i figured that this would have to open up, but...
I didn't think that...
I just... I didn't think that would...
I didn't know!
I saw it, like, at the very worst second.
Thank you so much for the super chat!
Thank you!
Whoa.
I think I go...
This way.
Perhaps.
What does this do?
What the heck?
Oh, there's stuff here.
There's a magnet.
Oh!
It's a big magnet!
Cool!
How am I supposed to get back up there again?
Maybe like this.
Splat.
That's so funny.
Oh, what wrong button?
Oh, jeez.
Taking a drink at the moment.
I didn't know.
Go, go, go, go!
Yes.
Little baby.
Thank God you're a baby.
That seems bad.
Oh my god.
Wait, this seems worse.
Um, wait.
Oh, I see the chain.
Uh-oh.
Uh, oh!
Oh, man.
Wait, I'm not crushed yet.
Oh.
But I am sliced!
Oh, wait, don't do that.
Okay, I'm gonna climb to the very tippy top so it doesn't
I'm like all topsy-turvy, I have no idea what the depth of
anything is anymore.
It's not getting closer, is it?
No.
What
is, I thought everything had stopped moving.
Hello, Minto.
Hello!
I thought it had stopped.
The gears of time had ceased.
I see it now.
I see all the zips and the zaps.
I see it.
Kua Vara, Kua Vara.
I know what I must do.
The gears of time never cease me.
Don't say that.
Okay, wait.
I was afraid of that.
Oh, my gosh.
As soon as I jumped, I was like, I think I'm going to get...
I'm going to get got.
Bad haircut.
They gave me the low taper fade.
I don't even know.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, God.
Give me time.
His hair got chopped and he died.
He died because he died of cringe.
He was like, oh, it's such an ugly haircut.
Dies of cringe.
Okay.
Be ready.
Be ready to jump.
Yes!
Are we still turning?
Yes.
Nice!
Oh, I think I just heard it locked.
Does that mean I can drop now?
I'll try to...
There we go.
Yeah!
Locked.
More spinning...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Wait, what?
Ah!
Oh!
Wait!
I need to climb on top of you.
Oh!
It's even more funny because it's silent.
Okay, I think I get on top of the box so that I can, um, so
that I can, uh, jump over the boulder.
I believe I believe that's what I'm supposed to do
Jump I don't know it seems kind of It seems kind of short
the box We got indeed There needs to be some sort of sound
effect I fear I feel there needs to be some sort of sound
effect
Instead...
Oh.
Oh, oops, there we go.
First you don't get got by the box.
And then push, push, push, push, push, push, push.
Push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push.
Push, push, push, push, push.
Push, push, push.
And then do I climb it?
And then do I jump it?
Yeah.
Oh!
The light is following.
Oh, the light is.
Butterfly.
Yes.
Do I follow you?
Hey, listen.
Grass!
Wait, a person.
Oh.
No!
Wait, but there was a person!
Was there light in here?
Please, there was light somewhere, right?
Yes, this one.
I'm going to go back and she'll be gone.
Oh, wait, what was that sound?
She got crushed.
She's...
Wait, what is this?
Oh, um...
Wait, where did the grass go?
Uh-oh.
Guys?
Oh, no.
Buttgrass.
No!
I think I can make it.
Run, run, run!
Jump!
Nice.
Oh, wait.
This one's tricky, maybe.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Oh!
Definitely not made that.
Oh, come on.
I made this one.
Come on.
I thought maybe I would go back and get the like I can't
turn around though for the for the ladder squish squish
squash oh my
god oh but your toe your fingies don't get don't get got huh
is that the case
I played this years ago and enjoyed it very atmospheric it
is very atmospheric yes
and jump jump oh my gosh I still think it was too slow
there we go run run run this one's tricky what happens if
you let the conveyor belt carry you back Probably death.
Probably death.
I don't see.
I was like looking maybe if there's like a little pixel
perfect hole.
Oh, I think I get it.
Wait.
Oh, no.
What I was going to try and do was if I tried to force
myself to walk left, you walk a little bit slow.
Like, see like that, you can walk fast.
So I was going to try and force myself to stay left.
I don't know if I'm going to make this.
Oh, I did.
But.
So that I could then be on the platform.
Unless that's what you do.
And you just have to be really good at it.
Yeah, like on the edge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You see how it sticks out right there?
Can you hang on?
Oh!
You can!
Wait, get up.
Get up!
Get up, kid!
Oh my gosh.
Please!
Eat my breadworm!
Eat it!
Yes, thank you.
Oh, but I think I have to go back now, right?
I think.
Oh wait!
Ah!
Oh, good.
Oh, good checkpoint.
Good checkpoint.
Please, please come back down.
Oh, maybe I can.
I don't know if I can reach it.
Oops.
Can I push these?
Yes, I can.
Oh, not enough.
Not enough.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I forgot to not...
To...
Just hold on.
I forgot.
Okay, okay, okay.
Here we go.
Oh.
Well.
The world's softest noggin.
Truly.
Oh, he's got group strength 100, but when it comes to his
little brain.
Whoop!
First try.
You forgoor to hold!
First try, first try.
What is this?
Ride the crates.
Wait, was this all optional?
No.
Oh, you're telling me this was optional?
Wait, oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Eggie?
Do I have to make it?
Wait.
You have to, like, this turns it the other way, no?
Oh, yes.
Oh, perfect.
Oh, my gosh.
Yes, yes, yes.
She's too good, Your Honor.
I know.
She was the best.
Hoi!
So close.
She was the best.
Hoi!
I
don't know if I want to turn that on.
Seems a little dangerous.
Is there a save?
I guess load chapter.
Hmm.
This one is frustrating.
The others weren't.
The others weren't frustrating.
I don't quite understand it.
Why don't I just go when there's no electricity?
It does save often, yeah.
Wait, can I go forward?
I killed myself.
Guys, if I can't beat it today, I wonder if I should beat
it, if I should play while I'm in Japan.
Oh, I'm guessing that there's like, that like this door is
open or something.
Or what?
Does this open or something and we have to go through?
But there's a lever up there, too.
Oh, no, no.
An hour and a half left.
I would...
That would put me right exactly up to the collab, and I kind
of want to make sure I eat properly before then.
80% done.
I think that's fine then, because then I could finish it
while I'm there.
It would be a very easy...
Well...
Oh, wait, can I...
I could desktop screen share or desktop capture I could
desktop capture while I'm there it's just my laptop so
there's really nothing on there yeah so we'll part two on
this game because that's okay um and that's also makes it
easy easy for me too because uh you know streams in Japan
what a little bit shorter just because you know i'll be out
doing things and being busy and stuff with with my plans
that i have going on so yeah yeah yeah i just really i
really wanted to get in as many streams as possible because
i know i was gone last week with stuff and then i'll be gone
uh i be i will be back on december oh my gosh just saying
december december 8th i will be back so it's quite a bit of
time um streams will be oh my god step stop making noise
stop it
streams will be a little uh kind of just whenever i can um
it's a pretty i have a pretty busy schedule this time so and
they probably will be like morning for the US.
So, yeah.
How much of November left anyway.
I can't believe that next week is the last week, the last
full week of November.
So it is like two weeks, but I'm going to try and get in at
least a couple live streams while I'm over there.
It's already Thanksgiving.
I know, I know.
I know.
so soon 2026 don't say that it's scary
at least thanksgiving for the u.s i think what canada had
their thanksgiving when do you guys have your thanksgiving
if anybody canadian is here or knows you're streaming mgs
delta with doki she said that but i told her i was just like
i'll try and make it i don't know my schedule yet i will try
to make it to doki's metal gear stream but i literally was
just like i don't know because i will be over there and also
i don't know what time you're gonna be streaming it at if
it's like 2 a.m my time and then the next day i have
something to do like but but she did ask me about it and i
did say that i would do my best to to make it, so I can at
least watch her play and get upset at how little she knows
about Metal Gear and also probably completely nerd out and
be like, and then, blah, blah, blah, oh, Doki, call the
Kodak right now, and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
Just got back from my friend's wedding to catch the end
here.
Oh, sounds fine.
I'm putting my arms up.
It's uncomfy.
Putting them down is uncomfortable.
I don't know I hope that I'm you know there were enough
streams this week I and hopefully hopefully I will see you
at the denser to group club right right right right so yeah
there will be some announcements so and you get to hear our
original song for the first time the full thing so for sure
um i they won't let me raid into the waiting room i've tried
actually let me let me message them uh uh uh uh steiner i'm
trying to raid my stream into the collab waiting room but it
won't let me can you give me perms please
cry cry cry cry cry cry cry cry cry cry cry cry cry cry cry
cry cry cry cry cry cry cry I think he's watching hi please
give me permission are you I think you have to allow me as
like a channel you have to be like this channel can raid
into or you can allow all channels to raid in.
Please,
please.
I'm waiting.
Battle at all channels.
Okay.
But yeah, thank you guys.
Thank you for all the streams this week.
And the debuts and everything.
I'm very tired.
I need a vacation.
But, alas, all my turn into work.
I had another vacation plan for March, and then that also is
getting turned into work.
I was like, well, November didn't work out.
I had plans in March.
And then it got turned into work.
Like, mega work.
Looking forward to the dance and the collab and song
premiere.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
How does that happen?
Basically, There are things that, how do I say, without
giving anything away.
Or rather, without explaining too much.
There are certain things that are easier to do in Japan.
And so I was like, I was, ouch.
I was already going to try and be in Japan for an idle
event.
That I was waiting to hear when it will happen.
And then...
They were like, oh, by the way, can we schedule this thing
for you?
Literally during...
Oh, yay!
Thank you.
In the middle of March, and I was like, oh, oh, I see.
Oh, so...
Yeah.
So, it just kind of happens.
And then also with this trip, I was only...
supposed to be in japan for like a couple of days and then
they were and then i got asked if i wanted to be a part of
something and i was like oh my gosh yes and then i got asked
another thing if i had to be a part of and i was like ah
yeah well i'm already over there so i know
so yeah yeah
suffering from success a little bit a little bit but it'll
be cool stuff you know for the future and like i i just love
streaming so much that i feel really bad when i am not
streaming um so that's why i do bring all my stuff to to you
know stream as much as i can when i can while i'm there so
yeah there will be some streams it will just be kind of
sporadic i apologize in advance.
But we'll do some fun stuff where I'll be like, I'm gonna...
Like, so... Like, these types of...
Like, like, streams are sometimes things that I don't do at
home.
I don't know.
Like, I'll just be like, oh, well, it's easier set up to do
ASMR or something while I'm over there rather than here.
I don't know why I think that.
I don't know.
I get stressed out doing ASMR.
I'm like, I'll just do it in a hotel room.
room.
Don't break yourself, K.
Ah!
Why did I... Siegel.
Make sure the Wi-Fi... The Wi-Fi... No, we'll be okay.
We'll be okay.
Immediately breaks voice.
Ah!
But I'll miss you guys.
I'll miss you guys and um yeah uh but i'll see you uh the
collab later i just wanted to you know it's it's difficult
to talk to you guys sometimes during collab so um wanted to
just be able to have our time together and everything before
i'm gone for a little bit and i'm not doing a 24 hour stream
this time i do have some shorts i need to upload so i'll do
that for the eventual actual vacation be good to our in your
ol senses knowing you'd need a real break yeah yeah i mean
honestly like the um just hanging out with the girls it was
a little bit of stuff that we were doing too but um it
didn't feel like work it was like a lot of fun so it was a
little work but um i find those to be breaks as well and
vacations as well
i don't know maybe i am a workaholic but i don't feel like
it but i'm gonna go now i'm gonna go eat dinner and um oh
let me set up the redirect into the den setu collab please
come watch it'll be so fun den setu dot bxc there it is okay
Don't be afraid to take it down a notch and be more low-key
with us.
What do you mean, low-key?
Oh, like, just like a chill stream?
Yeah, I think it'll probably be a bit of those while I'm in
Japan.
But that's, I hope you guys don't mind.
It'll be just kind of like hanging out and stuff, which I
think is fun too.
There might be a little shorter as well, which is why I'm
like, oh, if I can finish this game while I'm over there,
that would be great.
Because, you know, then it'll be a bit of a shorter stream,
but that's okay too.
Short and chatting and stuff like that.
Yeah.
We don't mind at all.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I appreciate it.
Okie dokie!
We will raid, we will raid, we will raid.
And I will see you guys when I see you later.
Bye bye!
I'll see you at the collab, hopefully.
Otsumi and to eat atashai!
Bye bye!